hey what's going on it's Bill Burr and
it's time for the Monday Morning podcast
for Monday
for Monday baby wow
20 May 20 [__] 9th 2023 that's what
I'm trying to say I'm a little
flabbergasted
what a weekend
what a [__] weekend of sports
that I had
they were for me man
I don't know if you guys are paying
attention but the Boston Celtics were
down
three games to none
they were halfway through game four
Charles Barkley and Shaquille O'Neal
were giving the Celtics the tongue
lashing they fully deserved at halftime
going like they're trying to win on
Talent they don't have any heart you got
to have a Killer Instinct and Shaq was
going hello
right and Charles Barkley said something
else and I was just sitting there as a
Celtics fan wanting to get upset but I
was like they're right
they're right they played the game their
Hall of Famers
when they make the list of the greatest
of all time they're on the list am I
going to dispute what they're saying
I even knew it was true even even a a a
almost 55 year old bald Ginger
no
that we weren't we weren't playing
around we weren't coaching right we
weren't doing anything [__] right and
all of a sudden they turn on the Jets
well lo and behold oh it's funny what
what can happen in four days
you could get hit by a truck
have a funeral be in the [__] ground
in four days ago a week earlier you're
sitting at a goddamn uh Diner
having a cup of coffee reading the
newspaper thinking you got a whole bunch
of more [__] weeks and you don't
same thing with watching this series
I was like we're [__] done
I'll be honest with you I don't mind
getting swept
I'm a big believer in ripping the
Band-Aid off if I'm gonna lose a [__]
series just get it over with
sweep our asses send us back to the
[__] goddamn Golf Course or whatever
the [__] basketball players do in the
off season and and we'll [__] we'll
try to do something we'll try and
rebuild
I think what we need to do is the
Celtics to compete with like what the
Lakers can offer off court is you know
instead of getting all these nerds to
fly in and go to MIT in [__] uh uh uh
Harvard
and Dartmouth and brown and all of that
[__] what we need in Massachusetts are
some good looking who was
all right
just fly them in for the day when you
have the free agent walk around Boston
okay and then you just have all these
[__] chicks walking down the street
making eyes at them and then maybe
they'll choose us over the Los Angeles
pylon Lakers who by the way got swept
[Laughter]
we don't win the game seven
what's you know what's the difference we
will be in well at least you know we we
had a better series I guess all right
let's get into it
close game the whole way the whole way I
thought we were going to win the game
they just could you know they had a lead
early and then we just kept being up by
six eight eleven thirteen fifteen nine
you know just kept doing that [__] but
they couldn't catch up with this
and then we almost choke it away at the
end and I'm like oh my God are they
really going to do this oh but you know
what are the odds you're going to win
three in a row
against any team you know
so I was thinking well at least they put
up a good fight you know
it's much more respectful than getting
swept even though I prefer it just to
get it [__] over with because I can't
handle aging
you know in dog years when I watch these
[__] games so anyway we're somehow in
the end we're up by three I don't
[__] remember there's so many goddamn
foul shots and timeouts and [__]
commercials
so Jimmy Butler's bringing it down the
court right
gets over half court
he's at the three-point line you know
where it's the top of the key or
whatever we got two guys up there we're
playing great defense the clock's
running down and then all of a sudden he
starts going in the corner and he's got
Al Horford moving lateral so you knew
exactly what was going to happen he was
going to draw contact which is such
[__] [__]
I feel he had no intention of that ball
going in
I think his number one thing was I want
to get fouled and take two free
unguarded foul shots and Jimmy Butler
being Jimmy Butler gets fouled behind
the three-point Arc I don't know if
they've changed this rule or whatever
someone was trying to tell me that they
did
but it's my belief that um
two rules that should just are just
no-brainers should be changed
is that if you're the offensive player
and you deliberately draw contact not
only should you not get a file it should
be a file on you
and that is the basketball version of in
the NFL when a [__] quarterback all
right with his [__] noodle arm under
throws a receiver the receiver stops and
fights through the defender and they
call the defender on past interference
I think that should be offensive passing
Affairs okay if I could you know change
a few things in sports I would also get
rid of that stupid safe space underneath
the [__] basket nobody's allowed to
be here so people can dunk uncontested
and then scream at the crowd like they
did something
um
anyway so we go to we got like
two point something seconds left they
put another 0.9 on the clock
which I love how people would like you
know bitching about that you know the
point Niger yeah with your [__]
difference that wasn't the difference
that wasn't the difference the
difference was
Marcus Smart misses the three-pointer
when he shot the ball Derek white is way
out behind the [__] Arc or he's near
the three-point line and what does he do
he cuts to the [__] hoop
just in case
the [__] heat is standing around
looking at the goddamn ball that was the
difference not the [__] point nine
seconds granted it gave him the time to
do it but still
if everybody stood around like the
[__] heat did
that thing doesn't go in Derek white
cutting to the [__] basket
the level of heads up play that was that
in in Celtics lore history whatever you
say remind of me of when Dennis Johnson
rest his soul Dennis DJ Johnson
immediately cut to the hoop when [__]
Larry Bird stole the ball from Isaiah
Thomas if you watch that thing the
funniest part of that play is Jerry
seasting like has like hot feet he's
like what do I do Dennis Johnson cuts
right to the [__] hoop
Larry Gibson and lays it up and it's
good oh my God this place is going crazy
Johnny most rest in peace right
such a [__] heads up play
and I'm so glad that that game didn't
end on three uncontested [__] shots
it's the thing I [__] hate the most
about basketball is the same thing I
hate about soccer you watch the [__]
world cup and it ends on three
uncontested like whatever like five
[__] penalty shots
poor goalie he he's [__] trying to
block a space bigger than a goddamn
garage or a garage as they call it over
there and [__] uh
England or whatever so anyway
incredible game and I think game seven
is gonna be a [__] War I don't think
either team lays down I think Miami
comes in there they're like a wounded
Corner animal whatever you want to say
these [__] are not gonna sit
here and be the first [__] team that
ever got swept in that organization with
Jimmy Butler whatever the [__] their
coach's name is I can never remember his
he looks like a Brian to me I know it
isn't
um
Pat Riley
okay that who [__] hates the Celtics
and is a Hall of Famer and there's a
whole bunch oh [__] sock drawer full
of rings as they say there's no way that
they're laying down so I am not in any
way shape or form thinking that we're
just going to win game seven I have no
idea what's going to happen all I know
is I'm going to age a thousand years
but uh as an old man I am on the
Instagram I am on the internet
I am a part of these things and there's
all these big stupid debates
you know about
you know who's the best who you know
blah blah blah blah if I see one more
stupid [__] argument
you know
people are sitting there they're trying
to say LeBron is better than Michael
Jordan
and I think that what they do that did
they're not even this first of all it's
different errors and then secondly
like
this is this is how I I as a as a dummy
myself how I I sort of Judge if
somebody's smart or not
all right being intelligent isn't
reading a bunch of books and then puking
out
what you just read to the nearest person
do you know a blue whale always over
flock of little tons that doesn't make
you smart because you know that that
just means you have a memory
all right true intelligence to me is how
you process information
and the level of empathy that you have
the most difficult of all emotions
empathy
which I've had to do the last two nights
I went out with my wife both nights and
both times she came at me at the end of
the night and I argued with her and then
in the morning I realized ah she was
kind of right
it's kind of being a douche and then I
gotta put myself in her position it's
not [__] Fair all right you're right
okay she does that for me I gotta do it
for her blah blah blah Bill did you just
in a roundabout way pat yourself on the
back and say that you're smart I think I
did
and one of the great things about doing
a podcast about yourself is there's with
yourself is there's nobody in about
yourself there's no one here to disagree
with me
so I stand by that
the level of dumb [__] that that [__]
people are talking like
LeBron is one of the greatest players of
all time he's one of the most dominant
players
of all time
all right but when you sit there and you
talk about you know look at his stats
it's like first of all
the [__] guy started playing when he
was 18.
now I know Kareem played forever but he
played Forever on the back end
he spent 18 19 from 18 to 22 playing
college he could have scored 2500 points
easy a year
in his [__] Prime instead he was
wearing his body out
when in four straight NCAA titles all
those extra games in March Madness so I
mean
had he just gone to the NBA then I would
think that LeBron would still need
another 10 000 [__] points okay so I
don't know how you can say LeBron is
better than Kareem Abdul-Jabbar
I'm not saying he's worse but how you
can just emphatically go hey guys more
points therefore he is better and not
like look at the [__] or say LeBron is
better than Michael Jordan the
difference between Michael and Lebron in
my humble opinion is someone who never
played [__] organized hoop in my life
the difference between the two of them
is Michael Jordan changed the game
literally changed the game LeBron hasn't
done that he's dominated the game he's
dominated the game the way Jordan has in
a lot of areas but he didn't change the
[__] game
because I'll tell you growing up when
Dr J was around and he was dunking on
people I didn't think anybody was going
to jump higher I didn't think anybody
was going to do what the [__] he did
when he jumped up when out of bounds
came ducked his head lifted his legs
went under and reversed laid up against
the Lakers in 1980. I was just like
there's nobody ever going to do that
again and then Along Came Dominique
Wilkins and Michael Jordan
and Dominique and Michael were going
toe-to-toe and then Michael just went to
this whole other level and he completely
changed the game before Michael Jordan
came into the league
okay
there wasn't anybody out there
that was going to tell you that you
could win a championship unless you had
a superstar seven-footer down low that
you would feed in the ball at least 50
[__] times a game
all right Dr J never [__] won a
championship until he got [__] Moses
Malone and that was the formula
and then Along Comes Michael Jordan and
he was like [__] you seven Footers [__]
everybody else I'm gonna play a
perimeter game and it and I'll go in and
I'll dunk on two or three guys at the
same time
that [__] he did against the Knicks
coming in going back out and then coming
back in and dunking on [__] what was
it Barclay I'm not Barkley uh [__]
Ewing and Oak nobody had done [__] like
that
okay so and I would say the guy today
that has that that I put in that
category as far as is change the game
without a doubt is Steph Curry
before Steph Curry came in the [__]
shots that that guy not only takes but
hits on a regular basis
you would get benched in the 80s for
even taking him like because you're
supposed to feed the big guy down low
this dude is I think Steph Curry is the
greatest
shooter in NBA history
and I don't even think
it's close
however watching people talking about
Larry Bird the young kids talking about
Larry Bird like they don't even realize
that when Larry Larry only hit this many
threes Steph does that in a [__]
season it's like well if Larry took four
thousand three pointers if that's what
the game was and he wasn't feeding the
ball to parish and Mikhail playing like
a team game
which is what you played back then and
that's another thing that Michael Jordan
changed Michael Jordan
when when somebody is that far advanced
in their game they actually hurt the
game because you got a bunch of less
talented people trying to do what
they're seeing and a bunch of kids stop
playing Team hoop for like it was like a
seven eight year period whereas everyone
was just trying to be Jordan and they
weren't
and I felt like the Sacramento Kings the
uh San Antonio Spurs in that
championship team that the uh the
Pistons had brought back like the team
game but everyone was trying to do it on
their own Kobe and Shaq were trying to
do that
until uh you know they got the free
agent coach
to come in the guy who whistles with his
pinkies right
he comes in piles on that thing and that
began the pile on era of like you don't
try to beat another team you just join
the team that's beating you
Phil Jackson and all of that [__] right
so
I mean Larry was an unbelievable shooter
okay but he was not as good as Steph
Curry
and and and so I just want you so I'm
not being like the old curmudgeonly guy
however Larry Bird also like the first
couple years of his career there wasn't
even a three-point line that had yet to
be invented in the league
um but I will say this as far as the NBA
goes I think the most talented
the end as far as like the level of
talent in the NBA I don't think it's
ever been higher than now
and and that's because it's now a global
game they draft globally or at least
they they're going way into Europe
they've gotten guys from China
uh I love when those people do the Trump
China and they do Trump
in China
um
and I feel like the players from Europe
have elevated the game it's made
everybody elevate
their game because what is what's it
there's there's two rounds
it's so [__] quick there's so few
spots and now you've opened it up to
another [__] continent or two
I mean
I mean I this guy's coming off the bench
I feel like back in the day could have
been All-Stars
um as far as like the the ball handling
skills and all that I know that they've
loosened it up but it's it's an
incredible level of talent so I'm not
[__] on today I'm just saying in
order to be in the Jordan conversation
this is my argument I think you have to
change the game and I feel Steph Curry's
done it because I feel like the kids
today when you watch them play are
trying to do Steph Curry [__] like that
they launch getting over the half court
line and they're just [__] launching
it with nobody underneath because they
wanted to go in and then they want to
run on it run off the court and whatever
because that's what they see him doing
so
um
there you go all right so all you
youngsters can now [__] take me to
task but I feel like that was a that was
a fair
argument
and and to further like solidify my
argument just you understand what I'm
saying like the people that I saw that
changed the game
in my lifetime
uh Dr J
Magic Johnson
there was never a guy his size bringing
the ball up to court those guys at six
nine were goofy tripping over themselves
they just didn't have the [__]
coordination Lawrence Taylor
Wayne Gretzky
Patrick Wa
it's a good [__] list by the way
um
Michael Jordan
Steph Curry
who else who else who else uh
honorable mention and this is before my
time Marlon Briscoe
on I hope I could set his name right on
the Denver Broncos
but unfortunately he was he was black
and he was playing quarterback
and if you watch him play the half
season they let him play and then just
drafted a white kid and shipped him off
to Buffalo and he became a wide receiver
if you watch how he plays the game
you're seeing the modern day NFL game
um
he would have changed if they gave him
the opportunity but uh
that's a good one for as far as like who
changed the game as far as like
quarterbacks I'd have to say
nobody off the top of my head
I would say more like coaches Bill Walsh
Bill Belichick
um all right I'm done you guys
understand my point you change they
change the game and then there's before
them and then there's after them
um
all right I I think I think I've
exhausted that topic but whatever we got
a game seven we got a game seven tonight
against the Vegas knights in the uh
Dallas Stars
um
and this is the time of year you know I
know it's the NBA finals with an S and
then the Stanley Cup Final is written
Stanley Cup Final and Stanley Cup finals
so I have no idea but I just love this
time of year if I say Stanley Cup Final
or finals or NBA Finals there's always
some you know [__] Wordsmith [__]
always have to be like um it's the
Stanley Cup Final there's only one final
you know
and this person that sends me that every
year used to annoy me but now I look at
them like you know what that's all you
have in life isn't it
you're that person at the party that
corrects people
that's all you got if you actually
working towards a dream and working for
yourself and you were your own boss as
much as they'll allow you to be I don't
think you have time to give a [__] if
somebody says Stanley Cup Final or
finals however I'm sitting there trying
to I'm trying to get these Expressions
right
I'm champing at the bit
to get these Expressions right you know
somebody said well I read one the other
day on the internet
where somebody said something
was said yeah it's worth the trade offer
instead of the worth
worth the trade-off
worth the trade offer
and if enough mouth breathers say it
that way
they bring Oxford and Webster to their
knees and they say it's also now
acceptable to say it this way in other
words we're tired of waiting for you to
find the right [__] answer
here so
anyway it is Sunday morning I'm in a
great [__] mood
um
how great was it uh seeing what's his
face of Barstool Sports Live
um
whatever making the live video of him
watching the end of that game if you see
the look on his what I love about the
look on his face you see how much he
cares
[Music]
and I have money on the game that that
was hurting his heart
look into your heart
um
anyway and then running around his house
and outside back I was just [__]
amazing
um
anyway
Dave Portnoy there we go Jesus Christ
I always get nervous when I say that
because then there's Mike Portnoy from
Dream Theater so I always [__] that up
because I got the cell phone brain right
now I think
um anyway so it's Sunday morning uh we
took the kids out to breakfast me and my
lovely wife
and we had a blast and and just they're
the funniest damn kids so my son I swear
to God he just loves no matter what you
tell him he just loves doing the
opposite and then he just looks at you
smiling
and if you try and stare him down he'll
stare at you back and then he gives you
a little smirk and he starts batting his
freaking eyes at you
and he makes you laugh every time
you know
I don't know what to do about him I've
gotten way better at though as far as
like
you know he got his uh he got his big
boy bed so now he has the freedom where
he can get in and get out whenever the
hell he wants
so I've had a uh
you know
I got it down now I just I don't go to
his you know how you know how I approach
kids the same way you approach a horse
you know what I mean you got to be
totally [__] chill
you know what I mean you can see and
keep them relaxed and then they'll go to
your energy if you go up there kind of
going like oh gee this animal's pretty
big they get uncomfortable you get
uncomfortable next thing you know you're
getting kicked in the [__] head and
you're on YouTube right same thing
happens with the toddler
Sean
excuse me taking a drink there um
yeah so he got up
like once
put him to bed at like eight he got up
like once and then I I put him in bed
and then
um
at like 3 30 in the morning he got up
every five minutes for a half hour
and I just kept walking back on buddy
buddy you gotta go to bed you gotta go
no no can't sleep in the big one you got
to sleep in your yard you gotta sleep
and you can't sleep in mom and dad's bed
you have to be in bed that's it and then
it's funny as hell like for some reason
when he says good night he just screams
it
'll be like okay okay and then you start
to walk out and he just goes okay night
night Dada night night and you just go
all right buddy good night you know I'm
trying not to wake up my daughter I'm
like all right good night good night
buddy night night well that's what he
says night well
good night sweetie yes he yells the
stuff he combines stuff and all of that
it's hilarious
so he did that for like a half hour
straight and then I finally got him to
just stay in bed
and then it's funny then he's wiped out
because he got up in the middle of the
night and then
you know he'll sleep till like
I don't know quarter to seven or
something like that so I kind of got
that down so I'm I'm very uh psyched
about that but um
it's a good thing man going out to
dinner or breakfast with the whole
family I left my cell phone at home
totally locked in had a bunch of laughs
and all that had a great cappuccino
um
I don't know I can't believe I already
got my [__] 10-day cleanse coming up
again I'm really [__] annoyed
I'm having such a good time doing
whatever the [__] I want
um
I don't know maybe I could just learn
how to like everything in moderation
then I wouldn't have to do this
like what if I just had one cup of
coffee
nah because I know what happens
I was actually the other day I had this
amazing day right I wake up and made
myself a cappuccino
did a bunch of work and then I went
flying with a buddy of mine
my instructor and friend and he knows
this guy who I'm starting to get to know
who lives out on the ocean
and he has a little house on there and
he has this flat driveway he also flies
helicopters so I went out and we landed
out there
we texted him he was home we landed out
there and he made me
um
it was a Armenian coffee
and uh
I mean I literally landed and he's like
hey what's up he goes you ever have
Armenian coffee I'm like
no I haven't but I'd like to so he goes
all right so he goes it's just like you
know it's like really like muddy on the
bottom and I'm like that sounds
fantastic
[Laughter]
I mean it's coffee other than drip I
just can't do drip it just tastes like
[__] dirty water to me right
so he made me one of those
it was [__] delicious was sitting
there looking at the ocean
and uh the only thing I [__] up was I
left my iPad on the uh
on the mount there you know I use it as
a backup
system in case I lose my screen
and um with foreflight you know it just
shows you where you are so I don't bust
out anybody's airspace right
and um
so it was a little overheated I just
stuck it under the seat
it seemed to be all right after that but
uh
just sat there having a cup of coffee
cup of coffee in the morning right and
uh
oh just looking back at the helicopters
to sound [__] awesome
the day is and I'll you know and my life
is you know these beautiful wife
beautiful kids
get to play drums fly helicopters try
out different coffees and then tell [__]
jokes and somehow be able to pay for
Cheerios I mean it's pretty [__]
amazing so I'm telling you guys this
because I flunked everything in high
school so don't ever let those [__]
they're not [__] they're just
institutionalized don't let them ever
make don't ever listen to those [__]
people when they go you need two years
of a language if you don't have this the
schools aren't the colleges aren't good
they've looked down their noses and
they're [__] poorly [__] yo
respectfully [__] you
okay
there's nothing wrong with doing great
in high school
and getting into a great school that has
an amazing sports program that you can
follow for the rest of your [__] life
which I think is awesome
I mean for me that's the reason why I
should have studied in high school not
because it would have made a break
whether I was going to be successful or
not
you know what I mean I mean there is
that if you do well enough in in high
school and you get to go to an Ivy
League
school you know when you become friends
with the Senator's son
and he accidentally kills his girlfriend
having air quote rough sex with her and
you know about it and you keep your
mouth shut
you know
that's a way to be successful
but for the rest of us
you know like I'm putting all the rest
of you in my my [__] dumb pool
um
you know it's uh
you're just gonna go to a school and
you're going to get all this [__]
debt
um
I don't know I'll be honest with you I
got through college for my parents
because they they went that route and
they were both professionals and they
they believed in that so I wanted to
make them happy and have a college
degree because they also just like
different eras in sports they grew up in
a different time or if you had a college
education that was a big deal
it was something you could fall back on
I still think it it could be important
but I just feel like unless you're uh
you know becoming like a veterinarian a
doctor a lawyer
if you're learning a trade you know you
go to look at trade school it that that
feels like I'm learning this thing
specifically to go out and get a job as
opposed to like you know
you know like an English major a history
major and just [__] like that like I
don't know where that goes
look I haven't been in college in 30
years so I should shut the [__] up I I
don't know what I'm talking about but
I'm just saying
all right uh I believed in all of that
[__] and I thought that I I was [__]
I thought about my sophomore in a year
in high school I was like I'm [__]
I knew academically I was [__]
I was like I'm gonna go to Notre Dame
and I'm going to become a lawyer and
then by the end of my freshman year I
was like maybe I'll learn a trade and
then I sucked at that too and I was like
I don't know what I'm gonna do
and that lasted from age 15
to about I don't know
22 or something like that nice seven
year period of just flailing
flailing well everybody else has [__]
seemed to be moving right along or
whatever so anyway
um
by the way I heard uh the style of
coffee
I don't want to start any fights here
but like
Greek
Armenians
and uh
and Turkish people
now I don't want to get involved with
Armenians and Turkish people that's like
Michigan Ohio State
um
if one of them
uh not I I don't I don't know enough
about it to get involved in it I just
know what one side says happened and
then the other side said didn't happen
and I'm siding with the underdog there
well what it never happened
um
anyway
uh why did I get involved in that why
would I get involved in that
you know I'm just you know I look at
that like Israelis and Palestinians like
I get along with both of them I don't
understand why that why we're [__]
arguing well I understand what the
problem is they [__]
kicked him out and Jesus Christ I can't
get out of this
you know it's like you know India and uh
Pakistan I mean I like both those people
I don't understand what they're fighting
maybe they're all just Led Zeppelin fans
and they don't want to give up Cashmere
is that what it is I don't [__] I
don't try to get involved in these by
the way I saw on Instagram a friend of
mine
put it out there that Henry kissing ya
turned 100 years old I had no [__]
idea that guy was still alive and I
started reading up on that guy and it is
a fascinating
you want to talk about
A A A Tale of Two stories however the
[__] that goes how does that go
I I can't remember A Tale of Two stories
I gotta add that to the list you know it
was a tale of two stories
um
if I used to know how that went how did
I just forget that I like panicked I was
like oh God Bill you're gonna use an
expression whatever you do don't [__]
use do it wrong
a tail
of Two Cities
not two stories
try that one out try out A Tale of Two
stories I guarantee you you'll have to
say it at least nine times in a sports
bar before someone goes it's actually A
Tale of Two Cities
I've had people do that to me and they
[__] it up so bad like verzie will [__]
it up so bad that I can't remember how
it goes and it was like I knew how it
went until you said the dumb [__] that
you said and then I do it to him because
I always get people's names wrong
you know
the classic one we were at Madison
Square Gardens at a Rangers game and I
was going first George Stephanopoulos
George Stephanopoulos
and he starts laughing he goes That's
not George Stephanopoulos I go then who
is it he goes that's [__] he goes now
you made me forget his name Jeff Gordon
it's Jeff Gordon I'm like all right well
he looks like his older brother
um
anyway let me uh
let me do the the reads here
for the week for the week for the week
oh look who it is everybody
it's so zip
um did you know that it can take up to
11 weeks on average to hire for an open
position that's almost two and a half
months so if you're hiring for a growing
business do you really want to have to
that kind of wait time to wait do you
really have that kind of time to wait
there we go
uh well if you're listening today I've
got some advice for you
stop waiting and start using zippers
um zip recruiter can help you find
qualified candidates for all your roles
fast and right now you can try it for
free at ziprecruiter.com how is it that
zip
[Music]
is so efficient and helping you hire
easy they use powerful matching
technology to quickly find and send you
the most qualified people for your roles
you can check out the people that it
sends you and if you really like one or
two of them you can personally invite
them to apply with one one click that's
how easy they make it which uh uh which
may make them apply even sooner plus now
Employment Plus here's how quickly zip
can work to help you hire four to five
employees who post on zip
uh get a quality candidate within the
first day so speed up your hiring
process
process process with zip recruiter Cy
3.8 million businesses have come to zip
for their hiring needs just go to this
exclusive web address to try
ZipRecruiter for free ziprecruiter.com
again that zip
recruiter
the smartest way to hire
all right is that it do I have I must
have emails for the week
right
does anybody know is anybody out there
babe is anybody can we go
um oh that would be a great if I could
[__] do that every week
when I go to uh do we have any reads for
the week and then we could cut to Def
Leppard is anybody out there
um Bill we've noticed in some of your
recent photos that you appear to be
slimming down what is your secret oh
come on you guys you're embarrassing me
I've been working out
my new thing is when somebody goes do
you want dessert I just say I don't eat
dessert the same way I say I don't drink
it's uh it's an amazing thing I love
saying it I don't eat dessert and I
always look at the dessert and I go ah
man I wish I did it why do I wish I did
it huh there's no nutritional value to
it I just want the [__] Sugar Rush
you know
the second it goes in your mouth and
that that [__] food heroine
sugar
and you go oh God it's [__] you know
bringing my energy up and all of that
[__] I just go I don't [__] I don't I
don't do that I haven't been [__]
with bread
and I've gone easy on the dairy and then
as far as my workout goes
if you're wondering I I've been doing
this watching these things on Instagram
about Mobility
and they're actually great like a lot of
them are great cardio exercises it's
sort of like uh calisthenics Mobility a
little bit of yoga and that type of
stuff plus my you know weight lifting
which I don't really go that heavy
do you know what I mean guys like
like I know a lot of you guys
like your dumbbells are all black and
gray and manly colors but the dumbbells
I use are the color of the rainbow
they're very inclusive the one pounders
the two and a halfs the threes
they're all like kid colors up until you
get into like 10 they do make some five
Ponders
that are the the manly
I'm pumping iron Schwarzenegger type of
thing
um
what do we got here uh all right oh
speaking of Pumping Iron I saw a fortune
uh famester in Bert Kreischer working
out with Arnold Schwarzenegger go see
Bert's new movie
uh the machine that is out uh
um all right thank you everyone for
watching the Paul Anka interview
and uh thank you to Dear James and
Marina Del Rey for hosting the interview
and anybody wants to write into the
podcast I'm sure I get there's a bunch
of people want to write in after me
talking about different errors in
basketball and sports uh the Monday
Monday Morning podcast at gmail.com
Monday Morning podcast at
gmail.com all right
all right sorry about that I actually
was like trying to switch screens and
then I hit the Siri thing that cut the
we didn't lose anything all right we're
good we're good I just had to listen
back to it doesn't mean anything to you
because we're going to edit this like no
time went by but I had a panic attack
like I was like oh my god did it shut
off like a long time ago
did they hear my argument about
Dominique Wilkins it's so important
um live streamer douchebags
uh hey Billy blood pressure
I'm not sure if you saw the videos going
around last few weeks there's this Punk
kid who does stupid [__] while live
streaming to his followers
um
the first one that blew up was him
walking into a guy's house
oh I would not advise that he's sweeping
his stairs and standing on the stoop
while this kid and his friends charge
into the house
what what the [__] why would you do that
you're gonna get shot his wife and kids
are upstairs and the guy is obviously a
bit concerned but he doesn't freak out
at the live streamer he he's actually
pretty calm about and says hey my kid is
upstairs you have to leave the wife is
worried because she doesn't know what's
going on the streamer's just laughing at
him and eventually leaves after they
walk through half the house
I can't imagine that happening to me
I'm a new dad and I would probably be
inclined to beat the pulp out of him I
mean I immediately figured
I just pictured getting the old softball
bat
you know
and just [__] smashing the [__] out
of his [__] skull dude somebody just
runs in your house and you tell him to
leave and they start laughing at you
um you know what that says to me that
kid has never gotten the [__] kicked out
of him in his life
so is he the one all of his fights or
he's never had a fight
um I would think if he had fights so
there's something about getting into
fights unless you're a [__] you you
really you gain a level of respect
for other people and you also have a
level of respect for violence where it's
just like I don't want to [__] do
this
you know even if I win my my [__]
back skin my hands are gonna hurt like
my head I'm gonna have a [__]
headache
and in the older you get it's like I
could get sued the cops show up it's
[__] nightmare anyway after getting
some notoriety from that he's proud and
does a few more crazy things while live
streaming there's one video where he
walks up to an older person oh no please
tell me he doesn't scare him and ask
them about their dog then he picks up
the dog and starts running away with it
he's laughing and running while the dog
is under one arm
and being absolutely manhandled
yeah this kid was not brought up right
so he's [__] with a with
this man and woman's
sense of safety with their kid and then
he's [__] with old people
anyway the kid goes on to say I'm not
sure how he wasn't arrested or even shot
I have no sympathy for these [__] the
guy is in 14 or anything he's in his 20s
if someone ran into your home or stole
your dog how would you react I just
don't see a probably
I just don't see a probably with someone
getting their kneecaps shot off if
they're going to take the offensive like
that and [__] with people I think you're
saying this yeah this kid this isn't
going to end well another one I saw was
this dude pouring out a red gas canister
onto the hood of a car oh I did see that
one the owner obviously assumes there is
gasoline in the canister
because that's what they usually hold in
actuality it's water the streamer pulls
out a lighter implying he's going to
burn the guy's car down the older man
who owns the pickup truck pulls a gun
out
but uses restraint
I think he had every right to shoot the
live streamer
well if he's in the truck and he's
pouring gas on it and takes a lighter
route you have to assume this kid's
trying to burn you to death
bad enough he's going to burn you to
death you don't [__] light another
man's truck on fire
I'm partial to try oh man you know
a car is a car but a truck I mean that
you can you can earn a living off of it
or pretend you do like I do
um
P.S I'm never the guy who thinks people
should be shot but when you're walking
into someone's home with their kid where
their kid is stealing a dog or threaten
to burn their car while they're in it
you deserve no mercy don't [__] with
kids animals or people's cars or old
people yeah no
um
when I was younger that would he needs a
good old-fashioned ass kicking or
whatever he was he needs a swift kick in
the pants that's what he needs and uh
I I don't understand why uh
I don't know it's it's it's a desperate
move
and I guess you can blame it you know
what that is I feel like that's the guy
version those are like man [__]
where like now there's this thing where
you can be like a like
back in the day [__] needed pimps
now they just need a social media
platform which is good we've freed the
horse but
I think guys are going like oh my God
that chick I used to bang
um is now making 200 Grand to show her
clam
on the [__] interweb there like how
do I do that what's the male version of
that
you know no one wants to see a [__]
ball bag
or the the hint of one
so maybe they're thinking like all right
I have to do stupid [__] maybe that
maybe and then I can win a couple
hundred grand
you know or like that kid there who who
goes in boxes former
uh you know
whatever but boxing champions and MMA
Champions and he's carved out this whole
thing and that kid's become a [__]
multi-millionaire doing it I think
it's just uh it's a new way of looking
at the world and trying to make money
um so I don't know
I don't know I'm just glad uh
I don't have to be a young person to try
and navigate that
um okay living in the middle of nowhere
uh dear Billy two times
I grew up in a really modest
neighborhood in Los Angeles that's a
nice way of saying people I grew up with
didn't have [__]
last week you were talking about moving
to the middle of nowhere and how it can
be more racist than living in the city
uh
uh I meant like more overtly racist
because I'm not going to sit here and
act like La isn't one of the most racist
places
you could ever move to it's just that's
not their
the story of La is the traffic the
floods
the fires the drought
Hollywood that's that's what they they
talk about they ignore all the riots
that they've had
and how most people of color seem to
live on Final Approach into LAX out here
um anyway last week you were talking
about I moved out of my childhood
neighborhood and out of La all together
to start a trade business with my cousin
we've been out here for about four years
and honestly it's the greatest thing
I've done for myself our families are
happy here and our business is doing
well that's awesome our kids schools are
better than their schools in La yep
that's the problem out here the teachers
actually seem to give a [__] as far as
getting weird looks and being accepted
it's been easy in La proper I would get
a lot of looks if I walked into a nice
store in Beverly Hills
or me and my friends
went to a nightclub in my early 20s we
were told we couldn't go into bars
because of our clothing even if we just
it was just jeans and a t-shirt white
kids had no problem but with us they
thought maybe we'd be trouble
yeah they thought you were in a gang or
something I've never been asked not to
enter a bar here and honestly we're
usually better dressed than most people
around here one time a customer asked me
if I voted for Trump he expected a hard
no but I told him the truth I laughed
and said I didn't vote for Trump but I
didn't vote for the other white man
either he laughed and then we started
complaining about taxes when in doubt
Bill hatred of taxes can bring us all
together
the only people who make my wife feel
uncomfortable are the white men who
overdo it with the we want you to feel
welcome vibe
it can be comical at times and
definitely tacky I appreciate your views
on a lot of things and listen to the
podcast every week on the job uh love to
Nia and the kids well that's awesome
there you go okay good for you
um
I'd love to do it I just worry if I
lived in the middle of nowhere like you
guys would never see me again
it just disappear
I would but I would I think I I could
definitely do that recluse thing where
every once in a while oh he's back you
know he's doing his [__] jokes down at
the comedy club he's doing an eight City
Tour and now he's gonna you know like
shade you know she like disappears I
love people that [__] do that
um all right left
a girl at the altar
oh my goodness oh my goodness oh people
we're getting we're getting in deep with
this one
hey Nia's Boy Bill last year I had a
crazy Whirlwind romance turned Horror
Story
with a lovely lady
all right well you left her at the altar
I mean that's not the best way to break
up with somebody but at least you
finally got the [__] seeds to do it
uh the super short you know what you
should do you should be a good [__] and
gradually pay her dad back
you know send us some cash every month
and in the end when you give them the
final payment it'd be like all right now
that we're even can we just
shake hands and agree that your
daughter's out of her [__] mind
um the super short version we met
through a mutual friend and had it on
and off the charts connection after
spending a week seeing each other every
day she started moving the relationship
at light speed and asked to move in
together after a week and then a few
days later said we should just the lope
and already had a court date set
even though my inner voice was telling
me something is off here
oh my God does she have a dick what
happened I did what
is moving so fast you could find out
does she have all the body parts what's
going on here uh I did what so many
dudes do when a hot chick is banging
them and ignored my inner voice oh my
God
let me read that again I this is this is
the smartest thing on this podcast as
far as information I did what so many
dudes do when a hot chick is banging
them I ignored my inner voice
and many red flags and moved forward
don't ever ignore that inner voice women
do it I think when they get with a guy
that can take care of them
um
I'm just guessing though all right I
don't want to speak for women
uh I was able to convince her to
postpone the wedding but I did end up
moving in with her after about six weeks
then things went from great to bad to
unbearable once we were living together
all our crazy came out she was
incredibly controlling emotionally
manipulative and narcissistic among
other negative traits that made the
relationship turn into my personal hell
just a few highlights oh I like how you
going Sports Center on here
the first time I tried to go to work to
try to go work out at the gym led to a
three-hour argument about how I'm
abandoning her and she doesn't feel safe
when I leave
oh wow
I would have got into that argument in
my 20s and I would have had a three-hour
argument I probably wouldn't have been
gone to the gym
now I would have been like
all right I'm going to the gym and I'm
taking all my stuff with me if you know
what I mean
I won't be back uh one day I went as I
went then
uh one day I went and had lunch with a
close guy friend which led to a huge
argument because she told me she doesn't
want me spending time with my friends
without her
it continues she told me I can't watch
movies on my phone or in the other room
because she's afraid I'm watching porn
and she wants to see what I'm watching
at all times
then when I would watch Netflix or
whatever in our room she would get upset
at the movies I was watching
Jesus dude how long can you hang around
for this and the real deal breaker was
she told me she didn't want me to pursue
my dreams because I made my dreams a
higher priority than her
this sounds like a poorly like a lazy
written movie like How could somebody
really be this crazy anyway I could list
about another dozen unreasonable
arguments that she would unleash on me
anytime I didn't act think or feel
exactly to her expectations at our
wedding as our wedding date Drew closer
my anxiety got worse and worse until
that inner voice was screaming at me to
leave
dude you shouldn't have told me in the
beginning that you left that you left
her at the altar because right now I'll
be having a panic attack that you went
through with
you went through with it but I felt
completely trapped as her entire family
loved me and embraced me yeah they're
trying to get the What About Bob chick
married off anyway we had a wedding plan
that everyone was excited about and had
made plans to attend in the hardest part
of all is she had two kids who were
already calling me Dad
and I had really fallen in love with too
oh God
you left that part oh the week of our
wedding we ended up getting into an
argument that lasted almost two straight
days where I had no sleep and couldn't
eat finally a day before the wedding I
found the balls to accept the reality
that there was no way this relationship
was the right one for me I left our
house got in my car drove away as She
chased me down the street pleading for
me to come back of course I got nasty
messages and threats from her family
well I guess they're not nice as the
news broke that I had called off the
wedding a day before she even told a
bunch of people I left her at the altar
which wasn't exactly true but close
enough
oh my god dude
I just pictured the end of the chain
Texas Chainsaw Massacre as you're
driving away and she's spinning around
with a chainsaw in the middle of the
[__] road
good for you man
every time I hear you in the lovely knee
interact on your podcast it seems like
you two are perfect for each other and
that you generally love each other's
company and it made me curious did you
have any serious relationship
before finding Nia that seemed like they
might be the one but ended badly or were
you ever in a relationship with a woman
who seemed like a dream but turned into
a nightmare like my situation always Nia
your first serious relationship you
happened to hit a grand slam as a rookie
in the relationship major leagues thanks
for everything you do and go [__]
yourself
um no I was I was always a relationship
guy and I I dated great women and the
problem was me not them I you know I had
a couple crazy ones but like
you know I was also nuts so I was kind
of bringing that into my life but
um
you know and me and I we had like a
bumpy road where both of us were
relationship people but we would get
freaked out that we were in a
relationship which is why we were
together for so [__] long before we
got married and like
we always say like we should just got
married you know a [__] year in why
did we wait that long it was like well
you know because we had [__] to work out
but um
I have found that uh even if you meet
somebody that you that you totally Vibe
with you really have to pay attention to
the relationship
and you have to take care of it and you
have to like make sure that you're going
out
doing things and
[Music]
um
you know
I don't know this is such a big subject
I've learned and continue to learn so
much about it and you also like
you can be 20 years in like I am and
you'll discover this whole other part of
the person that you're with
um
and then you then you know that you're
like oh wow I didn't know that that was
a thing and oh my God all right
that I've been doing this this and this
and the other thing you know blah blah
or they want to do this thing I got to
support this or whatever
um
yeah but I but the biggest thing that I
would say is like
it should feel easy
you know what I mean like hanging out
should feel easy talking to each other
should feel easy not talking being quiet
should feel easy it should feel easy if
it's already hard
before you even get involved with
legally
you know being committed and having kids
and a [__] dog or whatever the hell
you do it's not going to get like
like less stressful not saying that you
know get married having kids is a
stressful thing but it's you know it's a
lot of [__] responsibility and you
kind of got to see the world similar
enough with the person or you're just
gonna be constantly [__] arguing
um
and then your kids are going to see that
and it's going to [__] up their
childhoods
um Good Luck
um
anyway uh mispronounced sayings
um hey Billy yellow stones
uh greeting from Down Under
I got a great one for you a maid of mine
is always the first to hang [__] on
everyone in our friend's Circle but
hates it when he gets it back recently
in a Facebook
uh he tagged a friend in a photo
of an old fat guy saying look Dan
I found your double ganger
oh my God needless to say he got lit the
[__] up by everyone it was the funniest
thing I've seen in a while uh for
everybody else is doppelganger
anyways I hope to see you in Australia
soon and look forward to every episode
Stay classy and go Fark yourself
um how do you spell doppelganger is it
d-o-p-p-l that's how I say it
double
yeah doppelgangers all one word
doppelganger and
Apparition or a double of a living
person he's been replaced by an evil
doppelganger
people ask what does doppelganger mean
how rare is me how common are
doppelgangers
the team concluded that the
characteristics of someone looking
exactly like someone else
in all eight features
Eight Features let's see that would be
eyes
nose ears mouth face
body
I don't know what else
[__] pinky toe um
is about one in a trillion this means
there's definitely a mathematical chance
for two top doppelgangers to exist but
it's most highly unlikely and they got
it they got a picture
okay well Jesus that's a diet
wow that is [__] Wild
all right I don't like looking at this
you know it's one thing if they're twins
it makes sense but it's just like
there's somebody on the other side of
the world
looking like you no it's [__] bizarre
bizarre
um all right that's the podcast
everybody uh
um
I don't know what to tell you I I
[__] ran my mouth for an hour I got
nothing else all right go [__]
yourselves and I'll check in on you on
Thursday